what would you say is the number one
reason why people fail not necessarily
why they make you the complete opposite
right lack of brains lack of effort lack
of brains lack of effort yeah they just
they don't do the work they don't learn
you know when you walk in the room but
when you start a business and you start
to talk about somebody you're never in a
vacuum with no competition you know and
unless you just extremely lucky and if
there's going to be competition that
means somebody else knows your business
as well as you do when you get started
and if you walk into a competitive
environment and they still know more
about the business than you do and more
about your customers you're going to
lose and but most people don't consider
that they don't do the work they don't
learn more about their industry they
don't know even about their business I
mean and so you've got to put in the
effort to know more about your industry
than anybody else and that's that's the
brains part and that's the effort part
as well because look if you're competing
with me you you better know what you're
doing otherwise I'm gonna kick your ass
you know and you're not gonna outwork me
and so you know the combination is
usually what kills businesses early on
more than anything